[Music]
I'm dealing with the future of the
planet
[Music]
under necessary shock to the system I am
human evolutionary change
bulletproof superhuman Lau bad guy the
mission has been compromised
we need help
[Music]
our targets name is Brixton he's a ghost
we're gonna need the best trackers in
the business Luke Hobbs on what you call
a nice cold can of whoop-ass career
lawmen always gets his guy we're gonna
need to operate outside the system
Deckard Shaw I'm what you might call a
champagne Robo rogue former mi6 agent
doesn't play well with others if we
stand a chance against bricks today you
guys have to work together
this job requires stealth
look at you I'm trying to save the world
which for the record maybe my fourth
time cuz I'm really good at it you have
no idea what we're dealing with
Hobbs is sure
you know war
you've got one
remember me
[Music]
sure what to think
[Music]
three shocks will kill a man there we go
the bad guy speech big mouth huh yeah I
thought it was cool things in the moment
you